aquí en los jardines de luxemburgo se
lleva a cabo una corta ceremonia cuando
se conmemora la abolición de la
esclavitud en la francia esto fue en
1848 sin embargo sólo desde hace seis
años se hace esta ceremonia de manera
como estuvo presente junto con varios de
sus ministros y autoridades locales él
no tomó la palabra prefirió dejar que
fueran estudiantes del colegio quienes
se hicieran las diferentes lecturas de
poemas hubo momentos también en
musicales y uno de los momentos más
emotivos fue la lectura de un fragmento
del discurso pronunciado por el
cristiano tuviera ella es la diputada
que hace exactamente 20 años pues se
promovió la ley que hizo que el estado
francés reconociera la esclavitud y la
trata de personas como crímenes de lesa
humanidad una ley que además ha
permitido que la esclavitud y este
pasado colonial la francesa se ha
estudiado a profundidad en los colegios
pero también que ha abierto la puerta al
debate acerca de cómo reparar a las
víctimas
esclavitud a sus descendientes que ya
sea una reparación moral una reparación
simbólica pero incluso se habla de una
reparación financiera por otra parte
varios se comentaban france24 entre
ellos la directora del instituto para la
memoria de la esclavitud pues que en
varios de los problemas que se están
viviendo en la sociedad actual francesa
provienen finalmente de la esclavitud
entre ellos el racismo y la
discriminación